good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe I believe in you and
I want to see that thing you've got
inside you explode out into the universe
to have a big impact and so to help you
on your journey today we're going to
learn how to develop high-performance
habits rule number two is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best and as always
guys as you're watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired and when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick with
yourself as well
enjoy
[Music]
motivation gets you going good habits
keep you going Jim Ryan the great miler
who never won a gold medal in the
Olympics for the 1500 meter told me
about 40 years ago dan habits gets you
could keep your motivation starts you
but good habits but it's like you know
it's like training the if I didn't train
as much as I did I'm 70 years old I
wouldn't look like I look and I don't
feel 70 people tell me I don't look 70
and I can normally work people a lot
younger than me into the ground but I've
been doing it for almost 50 years now
yeah non-stop non-stop
you will move in the direction of the
people that you associate with so it's
important to associate with people that
are better than yourself and actually
the most important decision many of you
make not all of you will be the spouse
you're choosing and you really you want
to associate with people who are the
kind of person you'd like to be you'll
move in that direction and the most
important person by far in that respect
is your spouse I can't overemphasize how
important that is you're right
the friends you have they will form you
as you go through life and make some
good friends keep them for the rest of
your life but have them be people that
you admire as well as Wykeham you don't
do that to that yeah some friends do
bring out the best in you and and so
those it's good to invest in those
friendships I and you know some friends
challenge you about things you're doing
and that you know that level of intimacy
is great the power of 21 and so when
I've been telling you to get that gold
get that dream and I'm just been telling
you drive it and drive it and drive it
and drive it what I've been talking
about is consistency and for some of you
for real for real you'll never have it
you'll never be it you'll never do it
because you don't have any consistency
you listen to me you were killing me and
you killing yourself
you start and you stop and you start and
you stop and then you start and you stop
and you're go you got there on the wall
you got the Bentley on the wall
you got the gated community on the wall
you got the degree on the wall but the
problem is you keep starting and
stopping and start and stop it and all
I'm asking you to do for me as I'm
asking for some consistency all right so
I'm come on to power 21 are you in when
I'm telling you I'm talking about doing
something for 21 straight days now if it
may it may not work I remember when I
first did this the first thing I started
my boy hollering he'll he gave me a book
called a book of proverbs right he told
me to read like a book of Proverbs a day
for 21 days like he's like he just
started happy he's for real we started
with reading proverbs something real
simple but he said II if you can if you
can do something for 21 days like you'll
never have to think about it I don't
know if you caught what I told you
I woke up at 3 o'clock this morning 3
o'clock burnt out tired like you know II
I can't do it I just boom went back to
sleep boom three minutes later my body
woke me up what am I saying to you I'm
telling you consistency happens my body
like yo he I don't know what you're
doing I don't know what you think you're
doing but we don't do that sleep is for
suckers
get up I listen to me not my mind my
body kicked in and sing get up we're
talking about consistency and so I read
the book of Proverbs 21 straight days
right and I started doing other stuff I
said we gonna exercise for 21 days I
just started trying to do stuff for 21
days just see if I can do it and what I
discovered is for real and I'm gonna be
honest with Charlie I did 14 days then I
started all over again I said at this
time I did 16 days and I started all
over again and I did 18 days and I
started all over again
and I did 21 some stuff I can do 21
straight days some stuff I got to start
and stop and start and stop and start
but when you get to 21 there's power and
consistency your habits determine what
direction you're going your success in
life your results in life are in direct
proportion to your habits what deep not
what you say you're gonna do but what
are you gonna do you've got to develop
successful habits and I believe that
starts with being a daily goal setter
and a daily goal hitter that you get
them you know too many people spend
their whole life they say they're
dreaming but they're really just pipe
dreams they're thinking about what they
want to be doing in 20 years and what
their plans are way out in the future
let me tell you what the future you need
to be worried about is not the next 20
years but the next 20 minutes what are
you gonna be doing what are you gonna be
doing to be effective when you get up
every day know your priorities life will
overwhelm you stuff will overwhelm you
the with all the information we have now
whether it's your phone where sometimes
I think we have smart phones and stupid
people I mean it is so easy to get
consumed by a bunch of stuff that is not
gonna get you where you want to get
to say every day I will do today what
others don't so I will have tomorrow
what others won't you've got to choose
to be effective know what your
priorities are know what your must dues
are don't let your phone
don't let your you know your tablet
don't let the TV don't let your friends
knock you off what are the most
important things to get done today Sir
Winston Churchill didn't have an inbox
he had an action this day box and so
things didn't get into that box that he
wasn't gonna deal with that day so may
as John Wooden said make today your
masterpiece get up today and get it done
finish the day attack the day and go
change your life the fourth key to
developing your new habit is to
visualize yourself performing or
behaving in a particular way in a
particular situation the more often you
visualize and imagine yourself acting as
if you already had the new habit the
more rapidly this new habit will be
accepted by your subconscious mind and
eventually become automatic like
programming a computer high performers
have more energy a high-performing
athlete has more energy than one who's
dog in it we know that there's a
physical vitality a mental stamina -
that goes along with their days that the
energy is just sounds like it's palpable
you can feel it around them and of
course it's not luck they're generating
that energy they're conditioning that
energy in their body by their training
regimen they're conditioning the energy
in their mental stamina by having the
clarity of what to focus on what not to
focus on and getting very disciplined
about where they give their time energy
effort attention so they're not pulled
in a million different places because
you know how it is if you're pulled in a
million different places or you're
multitasking dozens and dozens of things
you're kind of your energy it's
dissipated there's extraordinarily
focused and powered up with reserves
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I love to know what do
you think of this video what did you
take home that you were going to
immediately apply somehow into your life
for your business please leave it down
the comments below I would love to hear
from you I also want to give a quick
shout out to the legendary Brian Tracy
who knows a few things about
high-performance habits thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and doing the review and
post them to your Facebook page I really
really really appreciate the support and
I'm so glad you enjoyed my book thank
you guys again for watching have an
amazing day I believe in you hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
you must make a decision
decide clearly that you are going to
begin acting in a specific way 100% of
the time whenever that behavior is
required for example if you decide to
arise early and exercise these morning
set your clock for a specific time and
when the alarm goes off immediately get
up put on your exercise clothes and
begin your exercise session second never
allow an exception to your new habit
pattern during the formative stages
don't make excuses or rationalizations
don't let yourself off the hook if you
resolve to get up at 6 a.m.
each morning discipline yourself to get
up at 6 a.m. every single morning adjust
this becomes automatic there's a gap
between who people are and what they
tell you they want to accomplish because
in the beginning I hired everyone
everyone right not because I'm super
smart and thought hey I should there was
no one else right like we had the
smallest handful of people ever and so I
started doing the interviewing as I was
doing it I started realizing God these
guys tell me they want to do something
amazing with their life and if you just
listen like wow yeah like I want to be
in your team dude you're gonna do
amazing stuff and then you realize they
can't execute on that dream so if I
can't they they don't have the mindset
yet
like there's you could do an entire
podcast series on how to get the mindset
but I'll just use Carol Dweck and her
amazing voting mindset as I'm sure such
a good book I see Simon's the neck up
there who is also very influential in us
and she says some people either believe
they're smart is there ever gonna be and
that's that so they're gonna be ego
protective and they're gonna you know
try to thwart anything that makes them
feel like they're not the smartest
person or whatever and then there's
people with a growth mindset and they
realize I'm not the smartest person and
I'm certainly not as smart as I could be
yeah so even if I am the smartest person
ever lived I could get a little bit
smarter and so when they're confronted
with contradictory information they
learn and they soak it up like well
whereas other people are fixed mindset
right correct it's done like no this is
the way and I'm writing that's wrong yes
and I would say the word
everyone's on a spectrum right even I as
much as I believe in it and work my ass
off to be a growth mindset
I still have let's call it 10% where I
catch myself and like come on dude you
know better than that yeah but so people
that fall unless they sub 50% spectrum
of the growth mindset it's got to be 98
percent and then the last point and this
is one of my favorites and this is one
that people really miss out on is study
success successful people study success
success is not what we naively think is
just something that happens naturally to
some people and doesn't happen to other
people success is a very deliberate
conscious endeavor that you undertake
success is built over months and years
and it's done consciously and the more
you understand the principles of success
the concepts of success the more you
study people who have been successful
the more you see what it really takes
and that process of success the
principles are not always what they seem
and to me this is something that I
really committed my life to is studying
these principles I really love it
it's exciting for me and I really
encourage you to get involved with that
so that means maybe attending some
seminars reading some books watching
these videos learning about it maybe
joining a group of friends that are
successful joining a mastermind group
right be around successful people learn
how the success process works and learn
the psychology of success not the
externals of success but the psychology
that's what we're talking about if you
have to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
so it would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]
you